it's something to see is it not amazing
it's great to meet wonderful thank you
for we just diving in or we good I think
so okay come on yeah so I understand
that you're a big fan of your White
House science fairs and that you seem to
enjoy actually talking to scientists and
thinking about science where does that
come from you know my mom was somebody
who loved and I'm not pandering here
love National Geographic and she was an
anthropologist you know she's the kind
of person who would wake me up to see a
full moon if it was particularly
spectacular and would drag me around to
Natural History Museum's and you know so
I give her a lot of credit the memories
of my childhood in Hawaii are so
important to me
people always ask why do I stay calm and
in the midst of a lot of crazy stuff
going on well I always tell people I
think part of it's just been born in
Hawaii and knowing what it's like to
jump into the ocean and understanding
what it means when you see a sea turtle
in the face of a wave and the notion
that this would be inaccessible to my
kids or my grandkids is unacceptable I
live in Chicago it used to be that there
were patches of rivers and lakes in the
Midwest that would catch on fire they
were so polluted and now you've got
boaters and recreational users on those
lakes and rivers and now climate change
is going to be the biggest of challenges
because our capacity to generate energy
worldwide is still tied to fossil fuels
but if you look at what's happened in
the United States we've been able to
grow our economy and increase the use of
clean energy faster than anybody else
and reduce carbon emissions faster than
anybody else and what that tells me is
that old notion that somehow you can't
be an environmentalist or
conservationist without sacrificing
economic growth or standards living is
just not true I'm 55 well
believing the presidency and beginning a
new phase this is a time when you start
thinking about what are you leaving
behind when you're present in the United
States this strange privileged position
that you hold for eight years or less
[Music]
the scale of the issues that you deal
with they're enormous and the way you
think about it is each day you just want
to make progress you kind of leave it up
to the historians to decide what your
legacy was if we want to leave behind
the same kind of incredible beauty that
sustains not only our bodies but also
our souls then we've got to work for it
Teddy Roosevelt understood that when he
started the National Park System when
you look at the impact of the Clean Air
Act and how it's been able to transform
urban landscapes lakes rivers all across
the continental United States imagine
what we can do if we get serious about
clean energy and we get serious about
reducing carbon get serious about making
sure that places like this survive
[Music]